moving on to my magnum opus and my
favorite part of that press conference
and I screamed out loud when they showed
the footage kingdom hearts Kingdom
Hearts 3 announced Bria we knew it was
coming but it reinstall no release date
looks like they're really really sinking
their teeth into that partnership with
Disney mmhmm yeah that mean an ounce
tangled they had a guy who looked just
like sayin oh yeah he totally likes an
art um we got a new trailer this is the
first time we've seen any sort of any
sort of gameplay we haven't seen any any
actual uh like like in what we've seen
some of it but we haven't seen like this
like we haven't seen running around the
world right we saw more of those theme
park attractions used as summons I guess
is that replacement also it looks
different you don't know if you guys
noticed that but everything looks a
little more like smoother yeah I mean
the last time we saw it was a very very
cg trailer oh yeah I was you know I had
the wave of the enemies just enter a
riding along them and it looked mega
fake I'm not fake and like I was seeing
it now you can see and it looks really
nice it looks smooth it looks cartoony
it looks just like what kingdom hearts
on a next-gen console should look like
yeah but yeah I'm excited I mean it's
been so long since kingdom hearts are
kind of like oh my god enjoy the hype
train I train pulling into the station
look at that what's the scale of that
fight looked amazing there it's
something I've been hitting out quite a
bit in the parlor yeah huge scale boss
battles they're going for like a shadow
of the colossus kind of thing they're
also this transforming keyblade did he
just have guns yeah you said Johnny long
have we ever had guns I've ever had true
gun I don't think so no I think cloud
gun carrying around a cloud maybe I
don't know if Kyle doesn't carry on a
cloud what's his name oh no one of the
organization 13 I think as a guy's name
um but this is look at this this
incredible just sparkly and crazy yeah
so they announced a kind of partnership
with as in thats that's good to know
that Disney are working closely yes
Square Enix on the game and so they
talked about tangled was that was that
it the guy works untangled and in front
of him were tangled props so I'm betting
there's a
yeah your kingdom hearts 3 i'm hoping
for a frozen world maybe some star you
know it's going to be and I just really
want to see Mickey walk out and flip out
his key bait and it just goes and it's a
freaking blank paper I don't know how
much of that will get I think maybe at
the very least we'll get a key bilello I
star was a weapon but I don't think
we'll be going to any Star Wars world's
same same with my gosh maybe we'll get
like a pop in from a character i'm
hoping i would really want to see how
the salmon system works because that was
my favorite part of the original kingdom
hearts game which is like somebody being
a you know Sora who's essentially a
Final Fantasy characters and summoning
you know like Jeanne I think in five
years just like amazing but yeah
Tinkerbell exactly kill a monster for
you and the stuff like fighting in the
arena against cloud and and and going
through the waves of enemies that was
really cold man I'm just going to play
kingdom hearts again decided to see the
Disney side than the new final fantasy
side or one hundred percent yet the
Disney stuff is the the whole thing with
kingdom hearts and Disney is like 12
people trying to find each other and
mystical world and [ __ ] like that and I
just I that's what I care about please
don't put I understand they'll probably
she warns in final fantasy 13 characters
in there yes 31 that just came out
you'll run into lightning you'll do a
mission with her she'll yeah should mean
and then you'll leave her and you'll
never see her again for the rest of the
game you know I don't mind if as long as
they have they're not in there too much
yeah there's a final fantasy I mean the
kingdom hearts games trade-off nostalgia
so much that I if someone like lining
shows up it will be sparingly and
they'll have a crap ton of school and
cloud and so random seed and plant and
and use elder is it no.39 best final
fantasy everyone final answers Final
Fantasy 6 please don't listen to my sis
9 all right we're gonna fight anyway
screen will fight oh we're going to go
fight off screen now but what the best
final fantasy is that's kingdom hearts 3
let us know what you think of the
footage in the comments tune in to
gamespot com a week for more news and
previews coming straight to you from e3
thanks everyone
you